hostilities continue between armenia and
azerbaijan over the disputed region of
nagorno-karabakh
despite an agreed ceasefire martijnov
reports from a cathedral that was hit
last week and shows us some civilians
caught in the crossfire
the war in nagorno-karabakh is not just
about trivial territorial gains
it's a long-lasting feud with lots of
bad blood between both sides
and recently it has spilled into a new
turf religious
this 19th century holy saviour cathedral
was a place where soldiers and
volunteers alike used to come and pray
before heading into battle
that made it a target but it wasn't just
soldiers who would come to this church
the azeri military was battering the
town of sushi at that time
so aluna and her family decided to hide
from the bombs in the cathedral's crypt
one place they thought that was safe
from the shelling
but they were wrong
there were seven of us including two
children when the shell hit the
cathedral
it was deafening there was destruction
everywhere
masonry fell from the ceiling that's all
i can remember
two strikes obliterating everything in
their path
the altar the benches and one of the
domes have been completely destroyed
no place is sacred no place is safe in
this war
not only was this church hit twice but
the second strike injured three russian
journalists
one of them is still in intensive care
after spending several days in a coma
he believes the hit on them was
intentional the streets of sushi bear a
striking resemblance to those in other
towns of nagorno-karabakh
it's a place of desolation and despair
those who can fight are already on the
front lines those who had somewhere to
run
already have done but alona doesn't have
any choice but to stay
abused we have to fit in this small
shelter
with a kitchen and bedroom in the same
place we are too scared to go outdoors
when we hear the sound of the sirens
we're rushing here to hide
every evening there is an alarm we can
hear the shelling
people seem to be unfazed by the sorry
state of the cathedral
there's plenty of candles still burning
within the half-destroyed walls of the
church
people pray here for peace to return to
this land
sooner rather than later igurzdanov
reporting from nagorno-karabakh
rt azerbaijan's
president ilham aliyev has scouted on
the damage to that historic church in
the gonna qarabak he says the incident
needs to be investigated
and that if it was done by his forces it
was unintentional
armin is also accused azerbaijan of
shelling a hospital in the disputed
region this was on wednesday and it's an
attack baku denies
as hostilities first broke out medical
staff from different countries rushed to
the region
marty spoke with some russian doctors
who are currently in the conflict zone
it's no easy decision for any doctor to
leave behind a content life and go to
war
here of course it's not hand to hand
combat but the threat is there every
second
i just followed my heart i went through
the first war as a student
observed military medicine i gained
experience and admired the doctors who
saved lives
i think it was imprinted on my mind
having a broad experience in emergency
medicine
i didn't want to sit idle i wanted to
share my experience
my knowledge and save any life possible
at first sight these are minor injuries
small scratches
in fact x-rays show us splintered bones
and torn muscles
all this suggests that the weaponry has
changed a lot
there are very few cases of gunshot
wounds here basically these are injuries
from explosive minds
cluster rockets and so on they are high
energy explosives
which leave incomparable damage
renewed conflicts broke out over two
weeks ago but has routes that go back
three decades with on and off bouts of
conflict the contested region is mostly
inhabited by
ethnic armenians but is legally part of
azerbaijan
the azeri government reported again
thursday morning that its territory was
being fired upon
that was the sound of a shell hitting
the azerbaijani town of turter according
to the azeri government the
town in question came under bombardment
on wednesday
both nations though deny violating the
ceasefire since the eruption of fighting
many people
have fled their homes a few though have
chosen to stay
colon there have been countless attacks
this morning they shelled our soldiers
here
luckily they survived every evening we
sit here and watch the shooting
first coming from the armenian side and
then from our side
it hit these areas and then it fell on
the roofs of our houses
there is no fear our soldiers are
fighting over there
why should i be scared here we should
not be scared